bonjour et bienvenue nous sommes en
direct aujourd'hui pour ce jeudi pour un
un live sur l'Ukraine la guerre en
Ukraine n'est plus précisément sur ses
conséquences puisque cela fait un an
qu'avec la guerre en Ukraine il y a des
sanctions contre la Russie alors on va
faire un peu le bilan de ces sanctions
et pour en parler je suis avec Fabrice
nodelanglois bonjour Fabrice bonjour
Vincent chef au service économique merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous aujourd'hui
les internautes du Figaro vous n'hésitez
pas bien sûr à poser vos questions lors
de ce live on y répond au mieux comme
d'habitude Fabrice on peut revenir un
peu au début il y a un an la Russie
attaque l'Ukraine et très rapidement il
y a des sanctions qui se mettent en
place contre le pays oui ça a été très
rapide et alors pas unanime il faut bien
parler de sanctions
occidentales puisque des grands pays a
commencé par la Chine ou l'Inde non pas
pris de sanctions contre la Russie mais
l'ampleur des sanctions a quand même
étonné une bonne partie de la communauté
internationale et je pense la Russie qui
ne s'y attendait pas
[Musique]
hier de dire l'économie russe résiste et
globalement c'est vrai après dans le
détail évidemment on y viendra c'est pas
aussi simple ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que des sanctions ne sont pas faites
pour pour mettre à terre un pays plus
aussi puissant et riche que la Russie en
quelques mois c'est une aventure de
longue haleine Bruno Le Maire au
printemps avait parlé de guerre
économique il s'était fait taper sur les
doigts d'ailleurs par l'Elysée qui avait
trouvé que c'était provocateur comme
comme expression mais il s'agit bien de
ça c'est une guerre économique mais une
guerre économique de longue haleine on
essaye de réduire les capacités
productrices financières d'un pays mais
ça ne se fait pas du jour au lendemain
surtout quand le pays en question et la
Russie qui avait des coffres plein et
des moyens de les remplir on y reviendra
pendant pendant tous ces mois oui parce
que on le rappelle au début de la guerre
la Russie avait énormément d'argent dans
ses réserves ce qui pouvait lui
permettre de lancer cette guerre sans en
dire un trésor de guerre en fait oui ce
finance publique était tout à fait bien
tenu un pays beaucoup moins endetté que
la plupart des pays occidentaux un
budget quasi à l'équilibre et puis
surtout avec le début de la guerre le
prix des hydrocarbures qui sont donc la
source essentielle de recettes pour
l'Etat russe les prix des hydrocarbures
ont bandit donc les recettes on se sont
accrus d'autant que les sanctions au
départ ne portaient pas sur le gaz et
elle ne porte toujours pas sur le gaz
officiellement on peut toujours acheter
du gaz russe en Europe elle ne portait
pas non plus sur le pétrole et si on a
beaucoup parlé de gaz tout au long de
ces mois c'est le pétrole qui rapporte
le plus que ça rapporte plus de
milliards que que le gaz elle ne portait
pas non plus sur le charbon et au final
tout au long de au cours de l'année 2022
les hydrocarbures ont rapporté plus de
200 milliards de dollars à la Russie ce
sont plus de plusieurs centaines de
millions de dollars par jour donc malgré
les sanctions la Russie a continué d'en
changer un vrai un vrai trésor grâce à
son gaz grâce à son pétrole oui et puis
les pays occidentaux ne pouvaient pas se
couper complètement de ce gaz et de ce
pétrole puisque sinon il n'en avait plus
tout simplement c'était tout le problème
dès le début de la guerre les États-Unis
eux ont décrété un embargo contre le
pétrole russe évidemment c'était facile
les États-Unis sont devenus le premier
producteur mondial de pétrole n'avait
absolument pas besoin du pétrole russe
ce n'était pas le cas des Européens et
ils étaient encore plus dépendants au
gaz russe qu'au pétrole russe et donc il
n'était pas question pour l'Europe en
tout cas la question pour la première
économie européenne qui est l'Allemagne
qui était très dépendante au gaz au gaz
russe de décréter un embargo contre gaz
russe donc les les gaz au dollars les
pétrodollars on continue d'affluer vers
vers les caisses du régime de Poutine
alors qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui a fait
le plus mal en terme de sanction face à
face pour la Russie en fait juste avant
quand même rappeler que les sanctions
pour les anti-auto elles ont toujours
visé le pouvoir et non pas le peuple il
y a quand même toujours quelque chose
d'assez compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
pour ça oui parce que si on fera
l'économie d'un pays infinie le peuple
est touché aussi et effectivement même
si l'économie russe résiste les prix
quand même sont assez élevés en Russie
et on pourra parler de quelques
l'inflation est forte après les
sanctions effectivement visaient le plus
possible l'oligarchie avec des sanctions
individuelles aussi c'est pas vraiment
de la sanction économique mais les
sanctions qui empêchent les cercles du
pouvoir de voyager alors c'est toujours
très pénalisant du point de vue
personnel pour des dirigeants qui
avaient l'habitude de voyager qui avait
pour nombre d'entre eux des propriétés à
Londres
d'Azur la Côte d'Azur qui a envoyé leurs
enfants étudiés à Londres aux États-Unis
donc ça c'est pénalisant
individuellement mais c'est pas ça qui
grippe l'économie dans les sanctions
alors on a beaucoup parlé en mars
notamment
les médias ont parfois parlé de l'arme
nucléaire des sanctions en parlant d'une
sanction contre le système Swift alors à
l'époque à part quelques spécialistes
personne n'avaient jamais entendu parler
de Swift moi avant la guerre en Ukraine
Swift j'en avais jamais entendu parler
effectivement Swift c'est un
coopérative à système international qui
gère les paiements interbancaires c'est
d'ailleurs une sorte de société basée en
Belgique pour des raisons historiques
mais qui gère tous les flux financiers
entre banques et les pays du G7 donc
États-Unis et Europe notamment ont
décidé de couper la Russie donc les
banques russes de ce système d'échange
donc a priori ça devait faire très mal
pour tout ce qui était transaction
internationale même si un certain nombre
de produits par exemple les produits
alimentaires n'étaient pas du tout
soumis à embargo pour un acheteur russe
une filiale de ou un supermarché russe
qui veut acheter des produits en Europe
ne pas pouvoir payer par les les
circuits habituels que permet de Swift
c'était très handicapant mais petit à
petit les Russes ont trouvé des modes de
contournement et finalement bon ça a
compliqué leur vie il y a des circuits
commerciaux qui se sont compliqués on
passe par des pays tiers par exemple on
s'est aperçu que si les flux commerciaux
entre l'Europe et la Russie ont diminué
les flux entre l'Europe et des pays
comme le Kazakhstan l'Arménie ont
augmenté et les flux entre ces pays
Arménie et Kazakhstan et la Russie ont
augmenté aussi donc c'est bien qui s'est
passé quelque chose que le commerce a
été détourné mais ça fait des circuits
plus longs plus compliqués et plus chers
quand même donc ça ça fait quand même du
mal oui on disait en fait c'est c'est
c'est sanctions elle marche
non pas pour but forcément de frapper
dès les premiers mois mais d'installer
un espèce de poison long sur le long
terme exactement c'est pas forcément ce
que les gens lorsque le public avait
compris donc souvent les les soutiens de
la Russie où les gens qui sont
sceptiques se disent ça marche pas trop
vos sanctions mais effectivement c'est
l'expression de poison lent et est assez
assez conforme à la réalité il faudra du
temps pour pour que pour que ça frappe
on peut aller d'embargo des énergies
tout à l'heure pour le pétrole et le gaz
il y a eu quelque chose qui s'est passé
de ré-exportation c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait la Russie n'a pas le droit
d'exporter donc elle vend et puis les
autres pays vont exporter c'est ça qui
se passe alors il faut distinguer
plusieurs choses au jour d'aujourd'hui
la Russie est toujours le droit de
vendre son gaz à l'Europe mais il se
trouve que dans les faits l'Europe a
fait tout pour réduire sa dépendance il
y a eu aussi ce sabotage mystérieux du
Gazo du Nord Stream dans la Baltique qui
par lequel transitait une bonne partie
du gaz de la Russie vers l'Europe donc
les flux ont diminué mais ils ne sont
pas soumis à sanction en revanche les
exportations de pétrole russe notamment
par bateau sont maintenant soumis à des
sanctions depuis depuis quelques
semaines seulement il y a aussi un
mécanisme de plafonnement du prix qui
fait que la Russie ne peut pas vendre
son pétrole au-dessus de 60 dollars le
baril sinon il y a des sanctions et
alors on s'est aperçu si au début de la
guerre le prix du pétrole Brent c'est la
référence mondiale et le prix du pétrole
russe était quasiment au même prix il y
a eu un vrai décrochage le pétrole russe
se vend à peu près 20 dollars le baril
de moins que ce pétrole Braine mais ce
qui se passe c'est votre question
les Russes ont exporté de plus en plus
de pétrole à l'Inde notamment à la Chine
aussi mais l'Inde s'est mise à acheter
beaucoup plus de pétrole russe qu'elles
n'en achetait et on s'aperçoit aussi que
l'Inde réexporte des produits raffinés
dans des quantités plus importantes donc
on peut en conclure que une partie du
pétrole russe et raffinée en Inde en
Turquie également comme vient de le
révéler une ONG et que une partie du de
ces produits raffinés donc du carburant
peut tout à fait se retrouver
en Europe alors un spécialiste
m'expliquait hier que
si on sait
identifier chimiquement du pétrole russe
par rapport à du pétrole saoudien ou
américain si on se donne les moyens de
l'analyser c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
avec des produits raffinés une fois que
c'est raffiné un diesel venant de Russie
ou d'Arabie Saoudite ou des États-Unis
c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus compliqué à
trouver son ADN chimique donc votre
voiture si jamais vous en avez une roule
peut-être avec un peu de diesel
finalement venu fait avec du pétrole
russe qui vient d'Inde parce que depuis
le début de ce live on parle des
sanctions contre la Russie on l'a dit au
début c'est l'élection obsédées
sanctions qui sont occidentales mais il
y a la Russie a encore pas mal d'alliés
finalement oui on les a cités la Chine
les
occidentaux se sont inquiétés cette
semaine de d'éventuelles fournitures
d'armes dans la machine l'Inde qui
effectivement s'est mis à donc à
importer beaucoup plus de
pétrole russe et à exporter certains
produits depuis comme la Turquie membre
de l'OTAN mais dont on sait
le dirigeant Erdogan a une position
quand même très ambiguë et une des
plaques tournantes du commerce avec la
Russie donc effectivement la Russie
n'est pas isolée à l'échelle mondiale
est-ce que on s'attendait à ce que la
Russie résiste aussi bien au moment des
est-ce que les spécialistes disaient dès
le début qui pouvaient c'était possible
qu'il résiste aussi bien finalement si
sanctions et je vous ai dit il y a
quelques grands organismes à commencer
par le FMI qui annonçait une récession
majeure 10% de payer PIB en moins c'est
une crise extrêmement violente comme il
en arrive quand même très rarement et ça
ne s'est pas produit donc globalement
nombre d'économistes s'attendait
peut-être à ce que les les sanctions
fassent fasse plus mal on sait qu'il y a
des systèmes de paiement par exemple les
Russes utilisent plus le yuan la monnaie
chinoise pour certains paiements
internationaux des flux ont été
facilités entre l'Inde et la Russie pour
payer en devise indienne pour éviter le
dollar
et même si une partie des réserves de la
Banque centrale russe avait été gelée
des réserves qui trouvaient à l'étranger
là aussi ça n'a pas fait autant mal que
que l'Occident ne pensait mais on pourra
en parler il y a quand même des
industries qui commencent à souffrir en
Russie ah oui alors lesquels alors
peut-être la plus emblématique c'est
l'industrie automobile dans la
production à chuté de quasiment 60%
parce que dans le flux commercial
mondialisé la Russie alors comme
d'autres producteurs s'est mis à manquer
cruellement de pièces certaines des
pièces à haute valeur technologique les
sont soumises à embargo donc on est plus
il y avait d'autres problèmes sur le
marché mondial des puces mais clairement
l'industrie automobile russe a été
vraiment frappé alors si bien qu'on se
retrouve avec des des situations parfois
un peu un peu cocasses on sait qu'il y a
certains modèles de voitures russes qui
ont été livrées sans airbag tout d'un
coup la norme permettait de de garder
des voitures avec des airbags tout
simplement parce les composants
n'existaient plus Alain Barlet notre
correspondant à Moscou correspondant du
Figaro à Moscou nous expliquer en début
de semaine que un modèle particulier de
la dalle la dalle n'y va travel
ne sort plus que peinte en verre parce
que il n'y a plus que cette couleur qui
est disponible en ce moment après les
Russes sont aussi souvent c'est habile
pour trouver des voies de contournement
mais il y a quand même donc des pénuries
Alain Barlen où nous expliquer aussi
dans un tout autre domaine nous parler
de pénurie de boyaux utilisés pour pour
confectionner des saucisses des
saucissons dans les Russes sont sont
friands grand consommateurs et certains
boyaux qui venaient d'usine en Europe
ils ne sont pas interdites commerces
mais c'est juste ce que je vous
expliquais le fait que les circuits de
financement de logistique sont
compliqués les livraisons sont plus
longues elles sont plus coûteuses aussi
donc il y a quand même quelques pénuries
même si la vie à Moscou semble se
dérouler
normalement
il existe des pénuries et on pense que
ça va devenir de plus en plus compliqué
on peut citer aussi de l'aéronautique on
a parlé alors c'est compliqué d'avoir
des données précises oui forcément
de quoi il manque bien sûr mais on sait
que il y a certains avions qui sont
qui sont démontés pour prendre quelques
pièces pour réparer d'autres avions donc
ça commence à faire mal et oui juste une
on dit que c'est difficile d'avoir des
des informations précises notamment
parce que la Russie a décidé de ne plus
publier certaines données notamment des
données commerciales des données sur les
réserves détaillées de la Banque
centrale pour des raisons évidentes ne
pas dévoiler d'éventuels faiblesses
alors ces sanctions qui ont lieu depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine elles
avaient lieu déjà il y avait déjà des
sanctions depuis 2014 la Russie est
assez habituée on va dire à ses
sanctions et on sait le rappel que il y
a un moment dans la guerre on s'est posé
la question de est-ce que ces sanctions
finalement renforcer la Russie tout au
long de ces années alors on sait que à
partir de l'annexion de la Crimée en
2014 il y avait eu des sanctions et
surtout des contre sanctions de la
Russie sur les produits agricoles
occidentaux et des études tout à fait
sérieuses ont montré que depuis 2014 la
Russie a renforcée sa production
agricole sur certains produits et devenu
auto suffisante sur certains produits
agricoles ce qu'elle n'était pas avant
le début de la guerre au Dombas c'est
l'annexion de la Crimée donc d'une
certaine manière sur certains pans de
son économie oui les sanctions ont eu un
effet de
renforcer son autosuffisance
c'est c'est un fait indéniable alors
parce que il y a aussi la question de la
France par rapport à tout ça puisque
nous aussi nous sommes touchés par ces
sanctions d'ailleurs il y a un article
je vous laisse je vous laisse les lire
budget moral un an après la guerre en
Ukraine comment la guerre en Ukraine a
bouleversé le quotidien des Français
effectivement depuis nous aussi les
Français on est directement impacté ne
serait-ce que par le prix du gaz et le
prix du pétrole bien sûr et qui ont été
des conséquences directes à flamber du
prix du gaz a été une conséquence
directe de la guerre en Ukraine la
montée des prix avait d'ailleurs
commencé avant l'offensive et on sait
maintenant que Gazprom avait réduit ses
livraisons progressivement pas mal de
spécialistes pensent que c'est tout ça a
été quand même bien planifié et que les
prix avaient commencé à augmenter dès
l'automne 2021 parce que les quantités
étaient rationnées donc effectivement ça
a été les conséquences dont on a
beaucoup parlé la flambée des prix de
l'énergie sont n'était pas uniquement
liés au départ à la guerre c'était aussi
lié à cette forte reprise post covid ou
la demande mondiale augmentait beaucoup
et l'offre pénale suivre mais évidemment
la guerre en Ukraine avec la puissance
énergétique que représente la Russie à
accentué évidemment cette flambée de
l'inflation alors je vois dans les dans
les commentaires du Figaro quelqu'un qui
qui parle de mais est-ce que c'est
vraiment utile ou pas c'est ces
sanctions on va être résumés pour
terminer ce live Fabrice ses sanctions
elles sont moins impactantes que ce
qu'on aurait prévu mais elle pourrait
l'être beaucoup plus dans le temps long
c'est ça oui parce que
Vladimir Poutine a besoin et évidemment
de beaucoup d'argent pour financer sa
guerre pour soutenir la population par
des
allocations qui soutiennent notamment
les retraités il y a eu des
revalorisations en début d'année ce
qu'on commence à voir c'est que le
déficit budgétaire de la Russie s'est
creusé
et donc effectivement à terme parce que
les sanctions vont évidemment continuer
elles vont se renforcer il y a une
discussion pas plus tard aujourd'hui
entre les ministres des Finances des
pays du G7 qui sont rassemblés en Inde
qui accueillent les pays du G20 donc ces
sanctions vont continuer de se renforcer
et ça fait partie de aussi des pressions
psychologiques économiques de mener ces
sanctions même si le débat sur le
l'utilité des qui a pu avoir lieu à
l'égard de l'Iran de l'Afrique du Sud
qui a été un exemple qu'on sert souvent
pour dire que là elles ont été
couronnées de résultats c'est quand même
les sanctions économiques qui ont permis
de faire chuter le régime de parteid
l'Iran il y a des bas beaucoup plus donc
le sujet des sanctions est un débat tout
à fait légitime mais en tout cas
clairement les Occidentaux comptent bien
le profil ça fait partie de ce que Bruno
Le Maire plaît une guerre économique je
souscris à cette cette expression c'est
c'est la poursuite de la guerre sur le
terrain économique très bien merci
beaucoup Fabrice d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous les internautes d'avoir été
nombreux à nous suivre la suite du
programme sur le Figaro et sur Figaro
live ce sera à 15h nous suivrons la
conférence de presse du procureur de
Bayonne après le meurtre hier d'une
enseignante à Saint-Jean-de-Luz à 17h
vous aurez la question du jour on
parlera encore de la guerre en Ukraine
on se demandera si les Ukrainiens
peuvent ou non gagner la guerre des 2023
puis le buz TV à 17h30 et point de vue à
18h je vous souhaite une bonne journée
et restez avec nous sur figure live